it's got to feel dope man because like
you are not a new artist by any means
like it's like I'm not a new artist but
I'm a brand new artist but we've told
the story before like I met you at South
by Southwest in like 2000 yeah I
remember I was walking home 14 probably
I was walking home in the streets drunk
nobody you're staying at the same Hotel
no I think you yeah yeah you was in the
line for something we're we're at like a
hotel bar or something where it was like
it was like by the valet or the bar at
the uh that hotel that's like I remember
but I can remember walking down 6th
Street right lost yeah I remember
walking down 6th Street and nobody
knowing me you know a lot of us like
yeah a lot of less tattoos but just
nobody knew me anyway
now they recognize me through the mass
I'll be having a sheisty mess like this
one you put hands in my pockets [__]
like this maybe like Millie's would be
like how bro but um yeah I remember I
remember seeing you because I was
walking down 6th Street nobody knows I
said that's poop like cab I forget even
where I knew you from but you were doing
I mean I was kind of like back then I
was like on the blogs a lot with my
interviews and [__] yeah yeah yeah
they're like two dope boy days yeah
that's why I love seeing your [__] go up
because even at the time to me you were
like popping right you know what I mean
so yeah really popping
um but it's got to feel good to be on
such a long
journey of being a by taking this
Rapture series to end up doing you know
records with some Legends and then
obviously
Lincoln with Snoop Dogg and you know
what I'm saying like there's like I feel
like you've had so many moments in the
last couple of years where like
you know do you feel like
validated I know you've always known
yeah but like to kind of get the peers
to kind of give you that cosine that's
got to mean a lot man yeah I picked up a
lot of cosine like I picked up a lot of
cosines in rap
but then like I got cosigned by the
money that's what that's the one thing
like I wasn't turning the profit from
this [__] yeah you were kind of doing it
I was doing it just getting by like I
would make money I've been getting paid
for features for 12 13 years right you
know what I mean would that would you
say that was kind of more of the bread
and the butter like I could get features
I I'm doing my show as it get hot it
wasn't no real money right you know
and the second I did get a little real
money I just put more back into myself
the pandemic did it for me for real but
like I would say like yeah the
validation from you know whether it's
like you know I'm signing a kiss and I'm
like Snoop is like a big supporter of
mine and um just all these guys in the
game you know and and so so it's that
but then it's
see it reflecting in my bank account
like I got accountants now and [__] and
I'll be like damn like I really made it
like I shot a tear on a plane one time
like like for real like I just had a
crazy day and I just shut a tear like I
couldn't believe it like because I was
really thinking I can't believe that I
was dumb enough to believe in this [__]
that I made happen like yeah I mean hey
but it's hard work I'm sacrifice yeah
it's hard work and sacrifice and I feel
like sometimes you just got to be dumb
enough to believe you know if that makes
sense yeah that's the real [__] I mean
you had a lot of I feel like you had a
lot of like like uh uphill battles to
fight being the white dude rapping about
Street [__] yo bro it's almost
impossible it's like an uphill battle on
roller skates when you think about it
like because I'm actually doing
something that's never been done correct
because you know we know all the
different type of rappers that came
through hip-hop
and there's never been a white rapper
with the street content to run around
with jewelry on really in the trenches
really moving around really co-signed by
the right people [__] like that it just
hasn't happened correct ever ever ever
you know there's nothing close to it
except if you're looking at like my guy
like like Paul Wall in Houston right but
his content was more that Houston
contest it was more like braggadocious
yeah it wasn't like my [__] I'm telling
intricate Street stories to the point
where I'm talking about Nationwide
whether we're in Chicago Minnesota
Cyprus projects in East New York
wherever the [__] we had I got real
Street people Miami
kid the killers come to me and say bro I
[__] with your [__] so hard the way that
you yeah the way that you break [__]
down like I'm really embraced in the
trenches Nationwide
and um
because nobody would uh like people used
to think like this [__] was impossible
and I'm still not like I've never had
editorial playlisting on Spotify like
that really hell no bro I got 650 that
like so there's still things that give
like I love Spotify and I know y'all
will give me all of my it's coming
because I learned to not be the rapper
like burn a bridge and complain so I'm
not complaining I'm just saying the
other rappers three million on Spotify
yeah I got 650 000 without one with one
percent editorial playlist right my
shit's a little different you know what
I mean it's I mean you're about to
headline a tour yeah and I'm about to
sell out across the country hard tickets
so I had to do all my [__] Kev I swear
to God I had to do all my [__] by just
showing and proving because the industry
did not [__] with me I'm gonna tell you
something I never told anybody in life
no major label ever reached out or
showed interest in me never never still
to this day I used to lie about it okay
no there's interest today of course
there is today on God in heaven there's
interest today but
I used to lie about it my whole career I
swear to God just to people though right
you know just be like I'll be in an
interview and be like yo so anything
going yeah you know a couple Majors
interested live betting more yeah like
or I used to you know chill with girls
and be like yeah so you know Atlantic
Records they were actually taught never
okay no major looked at me and I've been
grinding for 13 years and I watched all
their artists come and go like I watch
all these people who were right here
with me get signed they're gone I don't
know where they are I'm here you feel me
so would you even consider the major
route now never I'd have to have the
most unique deal ever because once you
start feeling the feeling of your
catalog you know really residual income
here yeah bro I don't gotta like I you
know I'm I'm waking up on a certain
dollar amount regardless right because
of my catalog I can't imagine what it's
like to to not have a streaming catalog
and you only get these checks and
I'm like really bad with money I got a
big Advance on my last [__] and I
thought I was rich rich rich rich rich
rich rich last time I was in California
oh my God because you know I never
really had money like that right I got
that money boy
we stayed in that we stayed in a house
for like
first thing we stayed in the house
somewhere in L.A with the with the
basketball court
[__] however much a night that is
it was like I don't know three four
thousand a night we stayed there like
unnecessary yeah we yeah we stayed there
srts all type of cars I mean this is
this a new chain here this is new it is
fairly new I think serious huh yeah kiss
just gave me this chain this is through
kissing Mazda you know shout out to you
with the free chain and the free goddamn
Courtside finals tickets that's what
happens when you get successful you get
free [__] Jesus that's it that's fire